à nevers où le futur maire de nevers
nous attend denis thuriau vainqueur ce
soir face à florent sainte fare garnot
bonsoir denis thuriau nous avons évoqué
la situation à ne faire avec le maire
sortant tout à l'heure l'union a fait la
force entre les deux tours pour vous
donner thuriau
oui je peux vous avez tout compris j'ai
entendu monsieur sainte fare garnot
avoir la défaite arrogante moi j'aurai
la victoire précise et humble précise
pourquoi parce lorsque le maire sortant
vient dire je ne comprends pas j'ai
entendu les neuf et reçoit au premier
tour tout allait bien et qu'il reste sur
son sectarisme en disant qu'une liste
sans étiquette c'était forcément une
liste de droite je me dis qu'il n'a
décidément rien compris à cette élection
et je suis forte est d'entendre remporté
un peu partout en france des listes sans
étiquette de belles victoires savez
notre mouvement n'existait pas il ya
sept mois nous l'avons enrichi et j'ai
accueilli dans le cadre du deuxième tour
deux autres listes qui nous ont rejoint
sans leur étiquette et qui adhèrent au
projet que je vais mettre en oeuvre avec
eux vous maintenez qu'on ne peut pas
dire que nous l'air a basculé à droite à
moins
bien sûr que nous on n'avait pas basculé
à droite je suis un homme avec des
valeurs de gauche je l' ai toujours dit
n'y a pas besoin d'en partir
d'appartenir pardo parti socialiste pour
être un homme de gauche par contre j'ai
su j'ai pu fédérer des gens de droite du
centre les gens n'ont marqué
politiquement et j'ai multiplié ce
rassemblement qui aujourd'hui sera
salutaire et je peux vous dire qu'il
sera salutaire parce que je connais
énormément de maires de l'agglomération
qui n'attendait que cela et nous allons
enfin sortir du marasme dans lequel nous
étions tombés depuis 43 ans en tout cas
depuis une vingtaine d'années question
de lilian melet bonsoir denis thuriau
derrière vous on le salue d'ailleurs au
passage on voit guillaume maillard qui
est le leader de l'udps et jusque
derrière vous ça va se passer comment
avec guillaume maillard et avec
monsieur cordier de l'ump est ce que
vous êtes déjà d'accord sur un certain
nombre de mesures vous avez déjà discuté
comment ça va se passer bonjour
oui monsieur mollet nous étions il ya
quelques jours ensemble donc je pense
que nous avons rappelé que je vous ai
dit monsieur maillard et monsieur
cordier ce soir sont sans étiquette avec
moi pour le projet pour nos verres et
l'agglomération ils ont adhéré ce n'est
pas une alliance je sais que ça arrange
et le parti socialiste mais monsieur
sainte fare garnot des plus en campagne
donc il abandonne donc ce terme ils ont
adhéré à ma liste ils ont adhéré à mon
projet et ce saut ce seront les 85
engagement et plus il en faut je le
crains de nevers à venir qui seront
appliquées c'est un accord qui a été
établie entre nous donc il ya pas de
difficultés là dessus vous savez nous
avons su être intelligents nous
rassembler les manifestement quand j'ai
dit que j'aurai la victoire modeste mais
précise nous faisons quasiment dans le
cas d'une triangulaire
nous gagnons à très peu de choses avec
une majorité c'est quand même assez
exceptionnel avec à front national
affaibli et je m'en réjouis donc encore
une fois ça surprend mais les gens qui
ne sont pas suffisamment ouverts
d'esprit et bien tant pis pour eux nous
nous avons su réagir et proposer aux 9
et reçoit une autre voie ils l'ont saisi
à nous d'être à la hauteur et c'est pour
ça je vous disais à moi d'avoir la
victoire humble parce qu'il ya beaucoup
à faire